very excited to have a distinguished
professor and presidential chair and
information studies at UCLA Christine
Boardman she is highly accomplished and
she is the author of more than 250
publications in information studies
computer science and communication and
at UCLA she directs the Center for
knowledge infrastructures with research
grants from the Alfred P sloan
Foundation the National Science
Foundation and many other sources she is
a world authority on data science data
sharing information sciences and how
that can be communicated effectively she
is the author of several books including
one I'm sure she's going to mention in
her presentation we're absolutely
delighted to have her as well as her
colleague Erina pescetta who's a
research assistant also at the Center
for knowledge infrastructures she's also
a PhD candidate and Department of
Information studies at UCLA and she's
working on her dissertation on data
sharing reuse practices in molecular
biology and genomics and she has
research interests in open science
frameworks science governance models and
in more general the ethics and policies
behind data sharing code sharing and
other practices for open science we're
absolutely delighted to have the both of
you we look forward to your presentation
I'd like to take this opportunity to
remind our listeners that you have an
opportunity to send in your questions
via the little GoToWebinar questions
mission system during the talk and in
the last few minutes of the hour we'll
take some time to read off some of those
questions for our speakers and get some
answers to them so without further delay
dr. Bergman thank you so much for taking
the time to speak with us today and dr.
pizzicato as well thank you jack and
crystal and to the whole group and it's
an honor to be part of this as as you
said in the introductions we've been
working with National Science Foundation
and the sloan Foundation and a little
bit more indirectly with the National
Institutes of Health because one of the
projects that were studying that
Rena will talk about as the case study
here that is her dissertation is funded
by NIH and then I'm of course a number
of coordinating bodies including a
strategic planning panel for data for
the for the NIH and National Library of
Medicine a wider sharing and reuse are
hard to do
is a huge and kind of book length topic
certainly more than we can do in 45
minutes or so today so what we hope to
do is give you a larger frame and point
you to some other sources to think about
it I'll spend the first 15 or 20 minutes
giving a big picture and then a rena
will do her case study and i'll come
back and do the wrap-up for starters i
want to give you this larger framing
around data sharing policies we've been
thinking about open access to
publications and open data in various
ways for several decades and we've had
open data repositories for 50 years or
more in areas such as genomics social
sciences surveys and so on but has
really been ramping up in the last five
to ten years
the Holdren memo from the White House
and the Obama administration was the one
that required open access to
publications and to data for all u.s.
large funding agencies the European
Commission has been even more aggressive
in declaring that open open science open
access publications and open data our
official policy of the European Union
and so all new grants going forward are
required to have open data they're
making very specific plans not only
through the rest of the horizon 2020 but
into the ninth framework program which
will run from 2021 to 2028 and really
thinking about this as as the future
approach so the challenge then is to
think about how you actually accomplish
open data and read
on the ground now the book of mine that
dr. Van Horn mentioned that came out
about two years ago from MIT press I
surveyed a wide range of policies up up
to that point and I was able to
categorize the the various motivations
and arguments in these public policy
documents into four general categories
the one that you hear most often is that
research data should be shared so that
we can reproduce research and in some
cases that's feasel and possible but
it's actually extremely difficult and
extremely contentious in most fields as
to what rep reducibility actually means
it tends to be in a more computational
areas of reproduce ability is actually
feasible or accomplishable we can do
things we can verify we can validate we
can replicate the true reproduce ability
is probably the biggest challenge of all
the second category is making public
assets available to the public on the
grounds that most big science including
most public health and medicine research
is accomplished with public funding with
taxpayer dollars euros yen and so on is
that the public should have access to
the publication's and to to the data
they should be useful for research
purposes thirdly to leverage the
investments it costs a great deal of
money no matter what the currency to
accomplish the research and to produce
the data so in what ways can we leverage
those data and make them useful for
other purposes across time again not
easy to do but these are large goals the
last one which in many respects is
cumulative is to advance research and
innovation on the at least theoretical
grounds that if you make data more
widely available other people can use it
for unseen purposes ask new questions
build new programs
even build new new companies so that's
as although those reasons are why public
policy around the world especially in
the Western world are moving very
quickly in the direction of open science
and open data however we also know from
a decade or two of social science
research that it's hard to do for many
reasons not the least of which is the
lack of incentives scholars collaborate
with each other but they also compete
you know the first one to a finding gets
priority no matter what the prize is
whatever the journal article is whatever
the best job is scholars in all fields
including biomedicine are rewarded much
more for publications than for releasing
data one of the aspects of these
problems that our group looking at in
most depth is around the practices
associated with documenting data and
making them available in a form that
other people can use and we'll talk
about that today the skills to document
metadata provenance version control
connecting data to the software the
tools the calibration the instruments is
often a set of skills that's different
from the set of skills that's required
to accomplish the research the
information studies field is a part of
the data sciences where we're trying to
educate a new generation of
professionals to this will facilitate
those aspects lastly but by no means
least our questions of control and of
ownership its contentious as to who
actually owns data you often have many
hands maybe many universities in the pot
you've got different kinds of funding
models this is kind of a wide open area
and questions of legal legal
interoperability are among those on the
table in larger discussions of open
access to data where our group is
spending its time is right now I'm
really looking at questions every
in our opinion data sharing should not
be viewed as an end in itself releasing
the data doesn't get you very far if you
don't release them in such a way that
other people actually can reuse them and
these are some of the reasons that you
might want to reuse them to reproduce as
we talked about to replicate to do it
again not necessarily by the same
methods and means to verify to validate
we have found in our other research in
other fields over the years that
sometimes people are seeking data to
reuse to ask new questions but other
times they're using them for validation
or comparison almost kind of background
purposes getting them from say a
government sources feel ground ground
truthing it's called in the
environmental sciences and lastly to
integrate with other data and you'll be
hearing more about that in in the case
study integrating requires cleaning
reconciling standardizing in ways that
also can be a major undertaking in and
of themselves so now to think about what
are data in the first place we've also
found that one person signal is someone
else's noise just deciding what are the
data out of a research project in the
first place
can be one of the most daunting
challenges to get to the place where you
could actually make data usable by some
other parties here's an example that is
on the one hand a bit far afield from
biomedicine but one that's
straightforward to explain the
signal-to-noise issues we were part of
the Center for embedded Network sensing
for the 10 years of its existence as a
National Science Foundation Science and
Technology Center this image is one from
a networked info mechanical systems
built by some Electrical Engineering
teams that had had many partners and
was a huge advance forward in
environmental sciences because you could
get data at far more granularity and
more speed from the air the water of the
ground and look for things like
different kinds of harmful algal blooms
looking at things like a methyl mercury
contamination in rice fields some very
important environmental problems being
studied this way as we would interview
people we would find things like an
engineering researcher would say up
temperatures temperature if he's getting
the same signal from one day the next on
his temperature sensor he's happy he
thinks it's working to end for his
standards for his kinds of science it's
adequate we asked a biologist on the
same team the same question and this
long narrative here on the right is just
a sample from what we got he has to deal
with international standards set by his
field about the way in which you trust
temperature and the measurements that
the engineer would get was not adequate
he could not publish in a biological
journal with those measurements because
they viewed them very very differently
now neither of these people is right or
wrong they're both correct with respect
to their field and that I think again is
one of the fundamental challenges with
data sharing this image here and the
quote from from my book the big data
little data no data is where I ended up
with a somewhat phenomenological
definition of data to say that they are
representations that become data at the
point that you use them as evidence of
phenomena so almost anything in our
world could be data but it's not data
until you declare it to be data and
declare it to be some kind of evidence
again much of what we do is look at
those processes by which someone signals
become evidence for some kind
of phenomena this next slide gives you
the title of our current large
three-year grant from the sloan
Foundation which is if data sharing is
the answer what is the question so we're
looking broadly at why people are trying
to share data and what it is they're
trying to accomplish so we're trying to
explicate these concepts such as data
sharing reuse openness and
infrastructure across different kinds of
domains look at how practice is changing
and we've called out these three factors
which again I'll discuss briefly those
mixtures or combinations or
configurations of expertise from
different disciplines scale factors is
it a matter of the volume of data the
time period or what other factors then
thirdly and this the centralization one
really comes to bear in questions of
biomedical research so again I'll go
through very briefly and note that we
have publications on all of these topics
already that you'll find linked from the
Center for knowledge infrastructures
website we use qualitative methods we do
a lot of digging of publications and
websites we try to get the official
story and the unofficial story about
what people are trying to accomplish our
grad students and researchers spend long
periods of time on site i rana has been
working with this particular biomedical
group for about two and a half years
already really working with them
visiting their sites around other parts
of the US and only when we understand a
site well enough to be able to ask
fairly specific questions do we come in
and start doing interviews and she'll
talk a bit more about how many
interviews and where she is in the
process for this particular study here's
a sampling of the sites that we're in
right now we're not that big
team as it looks like this but we have
been in some of these for nearly 10
years and some of them for only a year
or so and I won't talk about them in any
depth the ordering here is more about
how long we've been looking at them
what's useful is that we have enough
grep to get some strong comparisons
looking at astronomy that it's focused
on a place the sky and the universe the
earth sciences where they're drilling
under the seafloor
the biomedical and the computational
science are both looking at particular
kinds of problems and the the biomedical
one is around data sharing and reuse in
what is remarkably interdisciplinary
context compared to the kinds of
research usually done in these fields
the first question then is that one of
mixtures no no matter how narrow a field
looks when you start digging deeper you
find that people have graduate degrees
from different disciplines different
departments different theoretical
orientations they use different software
different instrumentation all of these
things come together to influence the
collection the use and the reuse of data
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey which has
been running actually the the main parts
of it the first two parts ran from 2000
to 2008 but it was a decade or two
before that for the design the hundred
and sixty or more terabytes of data
looked like a vast amount at the time
they were building it it's not subject
by today's standards that again the tens
of millions of dollars that they spent
the new projects are much bigger than
that
so the Sloan Digital Sky Survey is
notable because it was built to be open
data to the world for education and
research from the first day but it was
built on proprietary software in
collaboration with Jim Gray
of the Microsoft Corporation who's also
turing the world or winner in computer
science
the large synoptic survey telescope that
is going to get 15 terabytes per night
and they're spending more than a billion
dollars on it it's well over a decade
along already and we're about five years
out the the target of course keeps
moving forward then they plan to get
data for about ten years there they've
got the problem of the the of how you
actually build a data Commons how you
deal with free-rider problems and
they're still brokering what partners
going to have access to it but they're
investing in open source software so
they're taking a different route even
than Sloane did in how they're
approaching open data what are the
mixtures many of these astronomers have
all their degrees in physics others come
up through much more observational
astronomy a great deal of computer
science is mixed in one of the people
were working with takes PhD students in
astronomy in physics and in computer
science these this project is a mature
discipline they have vast amounts of
data abundant data they have a long
history the infrastructure trusted
archives and they've been doing these
methods for a long time and that's true
across all of these by comparison in the
earth sciences we've been looking at
this see Debbie the Center for dark
energy biosphere investigations that
gets most of its data by drilling under
the seafloor
this also is a National Science
Foundation Science and Technology Center
that collaborates at about 35
institutions across the US and then it
make grants to those even more this
photo on the right is what we might call
library it's a repository it's an open
data repository but those are frozen ice
cores from under the sea floor and those
specimens are their primary data source
this drawing that our collaborator Peter
dart is driven shows you how all those
cores come off one set of cruises but
the physical science people take them
down
path and the microbiological the ones
we're studying
take them down another path think what
smote what was most striking to us here
is that decisions that are made on board
the ship are absolutely critical to who
can make data out of these for the
physical sciences this line down the
left you can store those cores at -4
centigrade for the microbiological down
the right you have to be able to store
them at minus 80 centigrade so unless
those are frozen cold enough on the ship
they can never again be used for
biological research search so those
early decisions are critical long term
in use and in reuse of data
so here the mixtures are on the domains
many different specialties and again we
have papers on this about the mix of
them working together this is a much
more emergent problem the data are
scarce they are not able to set
standards yet because you get one core
here you get one core there many
different questions and very exploratory
kinds of methods so they're trying to
build capacity as opposed to the huge
capacity that exists in astronomy I'm
going to go brief on these other couple
of questions so that we have time for
the case study the scale factors big
data is usually what people think is a
problem but rather we're seeing many
other kinds of scale are critical this
notion of the three V's goes back a
decade or so goes from the the business
world to say that the complexity of data
is a function not only a volume but of
the variety the heterogeneity and the
velocity the speed at which it's coming
at you we see the temporal
characteristics are important the
spatial characteristics and the variety
of personnel and the number of personnel
also to be key here's just one example
of that is to look at these the two
Astronomy projects look at this range of
time
forty-five years from the time of
inception of the first one of these
until the end of the data collection and
beyond the kinds of uncertainty these
people have to deal with is also how
they're thinking about how you build an
open-source how you think about data how
you think about sharing so again briefly
on the scale factors and we published
some of these elsewhere for you to think
about but there's the uncertainty in the
long temporal there's the scarce data
that are sparse there's the variety of
genomes studied and then again big
differences in some of these
computational areas we're looking at
thirdly and I do want to use this as a
set up for a Rena skate study around how
the degree of centralization matters we
have looked at we tried to compare what
happens in areas like astronomy where
you spend a decade building the
instruments building the data management
functions so that you can pull a large
archive together that everybody can use
as opposed to working independently
which is much more common in biomedical
and trying to integrate them later that
in many respects is a much harder
problem than the kind of problem that
astronomy is dealing with so with that
let me turn it over to I Rena who is
sitting here next to me and she will
give you the example and again she's
been in here for almost two and a half
years now the dissertation will come out
about a year from that o in spring of
2018 I think that's going to be a very
important contribution not only to
information studies but to the
biomedical areas in thinking about reuse
so Jana good morning and this is Irina
thank you Chris for the great overview
on this important topic in my
dissertation work really look at the
practices of data reuse and integration
in this scientific collaboration I'm
very interested in looking hat at what
happens
to recirculate that once they're made
available once they are shared them so
I'm asking questions such as with using
the data once they're available in open
repositories why and how my main case
study is a consortium for data sharing
biomedicine over the last two years and
a half I conducted over a hundred hours
of interviews and observations and over
30 interviews with the participants of
this consortium we have ten labsim
involved in this collaboration and they
are geographically distributed all over
the United States plus a team of
engineers and the scientists
investigated the Bolden Giza
collaboration they investigated the
developmental and genetic factors
involved in a set of rare syndromes it
is as you can understand the highly
interdisciplinary effort
indeed the investigators the spammer
molecular and developmental biology
computational biology medicine computer
engineers but also computer modeling the
goal behind this collaboration is really
to fund the collection of these new and
advanced genomic and imaging data that
is related to these rare syndromes and
by making all the data openly available
for reuse them the end end goal is to
encourage collaborative efforts and
systemic approaches to knowledge
discovery also to make the data sharing
process and reuse faster and also
collaboration happening faster
scientists are scientists who are
collaborating in this consortium they
are expected to make the auto research
data available prior to publication
which means that as soon as the data are
collected clean the curated they are
ready to be shared them just say it to
be more about this consortium and their
work the data collected by this
community includes patients images the
metrics for Anatomy norms
Phil typically matches the sequences
from genome-wide Association Association
studies but the results from gene
proteins function validation studies and
this is one of the challenges of this
consortium is that data are collected
from four different model organ
organisms so we have human surmise
zebrafish and chimpanzee so as you
understand that it's really a
heterogeneous set of actors them okay so
I want to present now my findings so far
as Chris was saying I will graduated in
a year or so so I'm still in the process
of finishing my data collection but have
quite some data so in terms of data
sharing practices what we are finding is
that most of the labs involved they did
they really didn't have any particular
problems with making the data available
openly available on the shared
repository this was partially we were
partially surprised because initially we
expected a scientist to be kind of
reluctant to share the data prior to
publication but this really didn't
happen all most of the data sets are
indeed collected by the common by the
community and are available on the
centralized database created by the
consortium however when we look at who
is reusing the data and how a set of
concerns and challenges emerged them so
basically what we are finding that is
that using the artists unpublished data
is much more difficult than sharing the
data in salsa
we found that data use practices are not
imagined ouessem but they really vary by
skills expertise disciplinary focus and
types of data so on one hand we found
some sheer concerns across most of the
scientists about Italy used on the other
hand we found some disciplinary specific
challenges so now I'm gonna go through
my findings
okay so let's start to be the common
issues with Italy user first we found
that almost all the scientists involved
in this collaboration they express the
concerns organ we use it over using
unpublished data so from the founders
point of view sharing data prior to
publication it's of course presented at
our strategy to increase efficiency and
making collaboration across labs faster
however from the scientists point of
view using data prior to publication
represented a breach in their ways of
establishing trust in others data so
most of the scientists reporting that
when they have to decide if they want to
trust or not a specific event data set
the fact that that data set is
associated to a specific study that's
been published in academic journal plays
a really important role for them to
decide or not a trustee status at them
um second point in time most we also
found that most study participants
expressed concerns over the quality of
others data so scientists reported that
about multiple occasions in which they
invested a lot of time and efforts and
resources trying to validate others
datasets in order to reuse them
however in multiple occasions they found
these datasets not to be a cure accurate
or not working for this reason the
scientist the time to reuse unpublished
data mostly in the context of a research
collaboration where they have personal
knowledge of those who collected the
data mainly because it they know it is
difficult to go through this process of
validating others data for reuse because
it takes a lot of time so they want to
avoid that if they already know the
scientists to collect the data they can
kind of skip this process okay my last
point here is that probably because of
this lack of trust in unpublished
and concerns about data quality some
participants are accessing and
downloading the data from the consortium
database to the goal of comparing these
data to the ones they collected
themselves so the scientists are still
collecting the data set some and then
they are downloading also kind of the
same type of data set from the
consortium database in order to make
comparisons and do some sort of quality
control but they're not really reusing
other's data for knowledge production so
we can see that in this case the
duplication of effort is not avoided
it's a little bit twisted so if you have
questions about these in the Q&A you can
I can explain better I don't want to
give too many details right now but this
is the idea okay so I just wanna I
selected to disciplinary specific
concerns about that are you suggesting
they are interesting so first of all
belonging to a specific domain or having
a particular set of skills greatly
influenced the way in which the data
were accessed and reused by the
community and this seems obvious however
whenever you make available data you
really have to keep in mind that you
have different types of users out there
and this means that you have to share
data in different formats a different
level of processing provide different
type of data analysis tools and so on
and my last point is related to some
concerns about using data and
approximation of results so let me
explain you DISA
some of the scientists are not all of
them some of the scientists involved in
this collaboration they work on
particularly rare earth syndromes that
are characterized by scarcity of data so
in other words there is really no data
or very few specialized data available
for DC engrams so what some scientists
are doing they are reusing data
collected by colleagues and available on
the consortium database for Derrick's
Berryman's however this data is close
enough that what they're looking for but
it's not exactly what they are looking
for some other scientists are really
concerned about this practice because
they're worried about using data that is
close enough but is not exactly what
they need this could lead to misleading
results so again I can give more
specific examples about this in the Q&A
so in general what I think we should
especially when we design policies for
the tertiary end user or infrastructure
for data sharing user I think we should
keep in mind that data use is not a
homogeneous practice but the set of
practices we should think about it I'll
use really as a process rather than as a
one-time action and then also we should
keep in mind the data are validated and
at the multiple times during the
research process and validating other's
data for reuse it takes a lot of time
and effort Thank You Arena as you can
see this is going to be a very important
contribution to the literature of
biomedicine as well as the literature of
Information studies so I thought this
was a good good preview of it for this
audience and we've also have several
publications already covering some of
these topics that you can find in our
link so let me give you just a few
wrap-up slides first to summarize our
research themes the domains consist of
multiples of domains and as you can see
again in this case study we've got many
different areas within this file
medicine and the fact that you've got
four different model organisms which is
a far more complex set of comparisons
then it's usually done in biomedicine
it's a good comparison to areas like the
earth sciences where people salt
self-identify with 50 or 60 different
sub domains and still they're trying to
share data bring them together and use
them so big data is a problem we all
know that
but it's not the only only part of the
problem is the bigness it may be how
long it is how diverse is what kind of
distribution of geography of language of
laboratories of specimens are involved
as far as scale factors the centralized
collections things like the the
Astronomy ones become decentralized in
analysis you might look at something as
big and relatively homogeneous as the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey but you may
take pieces of that and then combine
them with pieces this is from the Hubble
Space Telescope from Chandra from CAC
and others so become decentralized when
you start to analyze them the
decentralized data collections processes
like this biomedical sharing when you're
trying to bring them back together and
again later those are often the most
difficult to integrate and in that sense
some of the the data reuse problems in
biomedicine are probably as as difficult
as almost any other science and
certainly of the ones that we've looked
at in the last last decade or two some
of the conclusions that we find data can
be shared in many ways share bring
point-to-point sharing with your
colleagues you have the best chance of
transferring the knowledge particularly
tacit knowledge that goes with it but
that doesn't scale well something like
this biomedical sharing hub where you're
trying to scale by getting different
groups around the country to put things
into common hood scales better but you
can see the kinds of trust issues that
arise we feel strongly that data sharing
should not be viewed as an end in itself
but rather a means to reuse and much
more research in public policy should
look at these questions around reuse we
know that reuse requires considerable
knowledge about the data not just what
was collected but why it was collected
what the research question
were will tell you quite a bit about
what kinds of decisions that were made
the validation the trust in the data
occurs at multiple stages questions such
as data quality again are rising to the
top but data quality is at least as much
a matter of social trust and social
relationships as it is anything that is
inherent in the data per se stewardship
and sustainability is something we have
not talked very much about today and
there's an experimentation going on by
NIH by NSF by the European Commission
and others funding in this area about
should the responsibility for
stewardship live with the investigator
with the institution with the
collaborator with the with the
individual universities with the funding
agencies and all of these different
models are being tried but Trust is
definitely the overarching concern when
you think about data reuse what does
this mean for practice many if not most
of you are trying to share and reuse
data you may be running data
repositories you may be data scientist
data librarians archivists research
facilitators some suggestions here are
to think not about how is it done in
astronomy but how is it done in this
particular kind of sub domain and how
does this sub domain interact with
others we need to think about what the
level of abstraction is for data sharing
an integration before we can think much
about curation and reuse should we be
thinking about point-to-point
should we be thinking about contributing
to some large curator that long-term
memory model where you've really got a
long term commitment like libraries and
archives
the sooner in a project that a group
invests in data curation the more likely
you are to create data that are going to
be useful
definitely decisions made in the in the
earliest stages around what kind of
documentation what kind of data
reduction you're going to do will carry
forward if it's collapsed too soon own
you will never be able to separate those
variables again later for example we
encourage by infrastructure solutions to
think about shared tools and services
and different kinds of discovery
mechanisms recognizing that stewardship
is going to have to be iterative the way
that you keep and manage data during the
course of a one two or five year grant
it is going to be different than the way
a lab manages over the course of
investigators career or how a university
or a funding agency manages his
long-term back to the kinds of questions
being asked internationally the European
Commission through pretty much through a
gauntlet at the research data Alliance
meeting in Barcelona two weeks ago
saying that the next the ninth framework
project will invest somewhere on the
order of eighty to a hundred billion
euros of public money in research
funding between twenty twenty one and
twenty twenty-eight all of that will be
going into research that is necessarily
data intensive and compute-intensive
they don't want to see every single
group trying to solve their data
problems individually they want to see
much more in the way of community
efforts of infrastructural solutions and
approaches and so the research data
Alliance is but one place where people
are trying to come together to think
about broader kinds of solutions rather
than each lab each group each University
trying to do these individually because
these are very big and very large
problems let's end with just a slide of
acknowledgments again this is a team
project the six of us are the ones
currently involved at petered arch
who is now an assistant professor at the
university of illinois information
school is leading the astronomy work and
the undersea biosphere work ashley sands
who's now at the Institute for Museum
and Library Services as a program
officer has been working in the
Astronomy areas around a you have just
heard from on the biomedical bernadette
known as Bernie Randall's is working in
astronomy and computational sciences and
Malena Gulshan here in Los Angeles is
our data scientist and project manager
who keeps all these pieces together so
very much a collaborative effort and we
have had a number of other people
graduate from this group that we
continue to collaborate with so it's
been a team effort and I hope you will
explore some of our publications and
other work that we have done that
explores these questions across a number
of different disciplines let me stop
there and leave fifteen minutes for
questions because surely we have
provoked a number of questions I have
indeed Christine thank you so much to
Christine and arena for a really great
survey of a lot of the data sharing
activities which are going on not only
in biomedicine but also in many other
domains to struggle with the same
problem of this as you pointed out this
very rapid kind of you know firehose of
data which is coming at us and how we
deal with that how we share it turn it
outwards so that it can be maximally
used by people a couple of questions
have come in and they are sort of asking
about the role of various organizations
and institutions on how to promote and
encourage this one particular I want to
just kind of extend that a little bit
because I'm not I don't remember if you
touched on this or not but what's the
role of journals in promoting data
sharing encouraging it and using shared
data to support the content of the
peer-reviewed literature do you have any
comments on that yes I do and again we
covered a lot of territory here in the
short period of time
journals are certainly on a pope very
important part
the infrastructure and many journals and
I think pioneering in biomedicine have
required people to deposit datasets in
public repositories as a condition of
funding the work and that certainly
promotes promotes open science the
trade-off there is that we would like to
see those de to be deposited in
repository because that are open so that
you can get them and compare them and
look at them over time if you publish
things with a journal and the data set
only exists and say supplemental
materials and it's behind a paywall it
may be useful for validating or
verifying that journal article but it
may not be in some common standard data
structure where it can be reused by the
community so in in our research we would
say that the optimal model would be for
the journal to require the data deposit
but to deposit in a public repository
such as those run by the National
Institutes of Health and then provide a
link in relationship Phil Bourne wait I
think about 2005 if as the editor of the
plus computational biology journal wrote
a very nice little editorial talking
about how we should think about the
database of journal literature in the
database of observational data as almost
interchangeable and the richer you could
have those links and relationships the
better you could move fine start with
the day to go to the journals start with
the journal go the data and so on so
let's think in terms of as synergistic
relationship as possible great one other
question is because some people are
asking what sort of analyses are you
seeing come out of the use of shared
data then how do you measure the impact
fulness of that reuse does that make
sense
then the impact fulness of reuses yeah
so like for example it came one measure
the impact fulness of say somebody
taking data from a shared repository and
through their analysis they're seeing
you know a new publication coming out in
maybe science or nature a high impact
factor journal and perhaps that's a
measure of you know its potential impact
fulness or perhaps it's being cited a
lot so it's like Citation Index is
really big I don't know how are you able
to track that sort of thing because it
always kind of seems that you know
people are a little bit wary about
sharing data because they're not really
sure it adds any value because once
people have done their initial analysis
that they've ringed all the useful stuff
out of it are you are you getting a
sense that there's there's value beyond
that initial publication done by the
original authors that you know has some
impact on the field um yes this is Elena
so the situation that you described is
definitely the ideal situation where you
have a scientist with downloading data
set and running a new analysis finding
new things and you know and publishing
new articles with these new analysis
however so I've been observing and you
know conducting interviews with this
community for almost three years now the
fact is that even data reuse takes a lot
of time right so at least in my in my
case study they just started to reuse
each other data the the scientists but
so first of all it doesn't really happen
or I don't at least I haven't seen this
so far that you know you have a
scientist who goes on this repository
and download the data set and run a new
analysis is move it's always in the
context of a collaboration so first what
I'm really finding is that scientists
they establish a collaboration and then
you know together they work out of the
liked it authorship
who is taking care of which part of the
new analysis so even when you have a
reanalysis I think it's always in the
context of collaboration and it takes a
lot of time and effort yes I think Chris
want to add something here that I'm
going to take that up to a higher level
and think about the different kinds of
uses and reuses looking at the the
impact or the you know the contribution
of an individual reuse is no easier than
looking at the contribution of any other
kind of paper so I think the measurement
is always going to be a challenge we can
we can look for those the large one of
the larger questions is the difficulty
of distinguishing between a use and a
reuse and we have a paper that just came
out in the data science journal on
exactly that problem so if you think
about people you know do do it you know
building datasets
some groups their primary work even in
biomedicine is to produce data that
other people can you lose and so if
those people weren't just playing data
producers those data would not be there
in the first place
similarly if some astronomers were not
willing to dedicate their careers to
astronomy sky surveys those data would
not be there for anyone else to use so
is the first use of evidence from a sky
survey or evidence from a genome Survey
is that a use or is that a reuse that is
an unanswered questions there's a lot of
definitional issues here before we start
to try to put numbers on things the
other piece is a citation indicators and
data citation is something again we put
a lot of time into I encourage you to
look at chapter 9 of my book which is on
credit and attribution of data which are
really very different kinds of things
people use data from other sources that
they do not cite so for example I renas
a comparison between pulling data to
validate your own versus
pulling data for a new research question
we found the same thing and sans ten
years ago where if they were using it
for background calibration they were
using it but they didn't cite it if it
was part of a new research question then
they would cite it
so whatever indicators you're seeing are
there a floor by no means are they a
ceiling and we're only at the beginning
of people actually putting things like
digital object identifiers onto their
data sets a look at data site and look
at the work the California digital
library and others are doing on
indicators so until people start being
more consistent about citing their own
data and telling people where they are
on and citing data they use from other
people it's going to be difficult to get
those kinds of indicators that's great
we've had a couple of questions with
regard to data provenance as well as
common data standards for storage and
for describing how data have been
treated this also links into the
software tools and other processing
methods that people have used as part of
their processing workflows how important
is it to link not only the data but to
the the tools and the software utilities
that people have performed on the data
as tracking where that data came from
and what happened to it did feel born
feed you that a question no no that's an
absolutely a central question again
something we could easily have have
delved into here and something that's a
great concern to us and it's one Bernie
Randall's of our group is her
dissertation is going to look more at
that is in many cases if you don't have
the software you don't have the data but
let's face it it would be hard to find a
research project these days that doesn't
have some kind of software associated
with generating those data so you need
to tie those together and you need to
link them so things like the the
workflow models Taverna and others the
computational model
Carol Goebbels work and in Britain in
biomedicine are ones to look at their we
particularly been looking at Jupiter
notebooks and github some of the tools
that people use to tie together their
their publications their data and their
software and we have a lip piece that's
that's in review right now on the
Jupiter notebooks in astronomy and we're
you know will certainly be looking at
those in biomedicine and others do you
want to add to that around yeah I agree
with everything ambien we did these
analyses of how people are using the
Jupiter notebooks again to cite their
data and then to look at the data with
software and again what we are finding
in these other research is that even the
ways in which you can use it to be the
notebooks that you can you know store
your data in different places and link
it to the publication to the software
that it's not really standardized yeah
so there are many different ways in
which you can actually do that to
provide both the data and the software
as a package and we are definitely
looking into new tools that can and how
how officiants efficient is to sorry
enabling this process right yeah that
needs to be done but but let me put one
note of caution there is the rush to
standards can be risky there's an almost
line to be a trade-off in the point at
which you want to standardize so that
you can really get that integration and
that interoperability and areas where
you really still need to be pretty
exploratory and maybe not let a thousand
flowers bloom but let 500 bloom when
you're still working it out and if you
standardize too quickly you're going to
you know to lose certain line lines of
Investigation so this is one of the
things we're seeing in the the undersea
biosphere it's pretty scarce data
emergent kinds of standards and
practices it's a little too soon and
there
wrestling with getting standards there
where astronomy is working from
standards us called fits files that were
established in the late 1970s and
they're sort of stretching those the
breaking point and trying to decide
what's you know what's the next step for
them I think those are very interesting
points about standards and it always
seems to me that I've been involved with
several standards groups of that I've
been participating when over the years
and just when you think you've got the
standard you finally flushed it out and
whatnot you say okay so now here's the
standard there's some other group that
pops up like a mushroom after a
rainstorm with oh no we're going to
define the standards and you end up
getting a little bit of this not
invented here syndrome do you have any
thoughts on how to kind of socially
engineer that out or is it just to be
expected well the good thing about
standards is there some eight choose
from
that's right baby that's just the way it
is I don't know but it would be nice to
see a little more uniformity of it but I
think what we need to do is bring the
communities together and that's what's
been so good about the research data
Alliance which has grown this was
established four years ago but with the
first meeting got about 300 people this
meeting in Barcelona two weeks ago I had
620 people from 45 countries and the
membership is up to 5,400 people from
almost a hundred and twenty-five
countries in four years community it is
amazing and is the first place where
people from biomedicine and archeology
and astronomy and agriculture and the
United Nations could all be in one room
talking about questions like provenance
and versioning and integration and data
citation and software cite citation and
software sustainability and data
sustainability and this so I would
encourage those of you interested in
questions of provenance and standards to
get involved in groups in RDA or other
groups like that there's a there's
national groups in addition to the
international
before we reinvent the wheel too many
more times because we've done a lot of
reinvention here one final thing in our
last couple of minutes here is maybe the
each of you could comment on the role of
data sharing of provenance and the data
science behind it all in education and
training at our universities and schools
of higher learning and the role that
that plays in training our next
generation of scientists I think it's
kind of an auspicious question because
we are on the eve of some of the marches
for science which are going to be
occurring around the country and I think
that that's probably an important
message to to convey I was curious if
either of you had thoughts on that
subject yes some currently this class
has been teaching for a long time which
is data management and curation and
policies for research data as a PhD
student and hopefully for future faculty
and this this field i really believe
strongly in the role of education and
educating researchers in understanding
and all all the practices and the
policies around data sharing use and how
important it is to make sure that their
science that they're conducting is open
it's not just a matter of believing in
open science but you really have to know
also how to do it you really have to
know how to curate the data what's the
metadata schema what are all the
requirements from the founders and so on
so this is what Chris is teaching in her
classes and I think the students here at
the information studies school they're
very interested in this topic and they
are you know we often talk about how
this should be a mandatory class for all
like undergrad or maybe for graduate
students when they start approaching the
research context yes and we are
definitely trying to involve more and
more students from around the campus and
from different departments
perfect and just to wrap that up that
those are that was a real gift of a
question Jack is you know I think that
it's a two-fold problem one is as arena
has this very articulate said we need to
embed notions of open science and data
practice in graduate education in pretty
much every field it needs the part of
research methods from the beginning but
we also need to educate a generation of
data professionals and the you know the
information studies approach is to think
about this entire lifecycle of data and
from the origins all the way through the
long term stewardship whereas most of
the data science programs are much more
about computation and analysis and
findings so I would like to see us
produce a whole generation that can be
part of the research teams part of the
university libraries and archives and
part of the laboratory facilities to
really you know think big picture and
help build that infrastructure and we're
in early days but I think we're laying a
good foundation well with that I want to
thank Christine Boardman and I ran up a
sweat Oh for an absolutely delightful
presentation on data sharing reuse and
why it's hard to do and with some
potential solutions in there - thank you
so much weirdos just outstanding really
excited to have had you guys visit with
us today thank you everyone and we'll
see you next week at our next big data
it's a knowledge guide to the
fundamentals of data science thank you
again everyone have a great weekend
thank you thank you